2 tenho de dar razão a uma pergunta que
sempre me atormentou propõe é vencermos
a 1989 portugal
uma menina de 9 anos minoria étnica
vinda dos países mais pobres do mundo
moçambique carregando uma mala somente
quatro vestidos
essa menina era eu
o estilo cada manhã
era um verdadeiro exercício de
criatividade porque sair à rua era como
estar num enorme restaurante mas sem ter
acesso ao cardápio centena tristeza
isolada discriminada porque eu achava
que encontrará aceitação encontrava tudo
o contrário à rejeição aprendem desde
esta tão tenra idade que os nossos da
diferença
não nem se não tudo o contrário não
param
estamos separando em quando eu fui me
separando de mim mesma
da minha verdadeira essência apagando e
fui criando uma mochila de medos
ao longo da minha vida sendo esta foi
ficando cada vez mais pesada cada vez
mais difícil de carregar
pergunta é né o único bem estes medos e
pesquisando na internet e descobrir tudo
não ser humano nasce com medo todos e
cada um dos nossos medos são aprendidos
a inserção do 1111 medo das alturas para
quem for
então pesquisando cada vez mais
descobrir que todas as que temos nosso
cérebro uma espécie de biografia interno
que se dedica a registar e agravar
ambas as nossas emoções positivas e
negativas e vai classificando a segunda
os estímulos que vamos recebendo
eu fui recebendo esses estímulos porque
vocês sabem que as crianças e os adultos
podem ser num cruéis às vezes por isso
há que ter muito cuidado com o que
dizemos as crianças por cada palavra vai
transformando se numa crença numa
verdade a compartilhar a condicionar
essa criança
o fogo aconteceu comigo aos 35 anos
depois do estar em espanha
carregando a minha mochila cheia de
medos
por fim o progresso a moçambique com uma
oferta de trabalho
kan aos seis meses se desvanece ficou
literalmente com uma mão à frente e
outra atrás por todas as crenças
condicionaram fizeram com que eu não
estudasse então não tenha formação
universitária não tenha poupanças não
tenha trabalho só tem uma mochila cheia
de medos
então é quando eu decido fazer a viagem
mais importante da minha vida
decido viajar para o interior da mesma
nessa viagem descobrir nessa viagem na
tentativa de descobrir quem eu era
a tentativa de retorno hectare comigo
mesma procura saber quem era o que eu
estava feita para que eu estava feita
quais eram os bons talentos e descobrir
que todas as minhas verdades eram
mentira
porque michael jackson o de shakespeare
coco chanel leonardo da vinci e o
governo lhes eram artistas e nenhum
deles tenha morrido de fome a mim toda
vida tenha dito não faça isto não faz
aquilo não seja quem está com os
artistas são os mortos de fome
eu acreditei quando chega o instrumento
da minha vida também encontra totalmente
desamparada
nesta viagem ao interior da mesma em
busca de mim mesma para perceber quem
são os meus talentos e quando descubro
que sempre estiveram aí mas como tinha
afastado tanto da minha essência tem
asfixiado uma tanto quando se trata de
uma banda que começa ocultado durante
todo este tempo
durante este processo durante esta
viagem interna rasi é a minha mala de
medos e comecei a descobrir todos os
meus talentos e quando eu descobri que
eram todas aquelas coisas que eu já
vinha fazendo desde pequena é daquelas
coisas que eu fazia sendo repostas
esforço sem que ninguém tivesse ensinado
e poderá estar a fazer durante a
quaresma
não não me custava nenhum trabalho e que
além de tudo dar uma satisfação enorme
eo melhor de tudo é que não reconhecia
isso em mim o melhor de tudo ainda mais
é que estavam dispostos a pagar mais por
isso eu fui com o termo momento eureka
da minha viagem estava aí todos os meus
talentos já desfilar em minha frente
então foi nesse momento que eu descer de
levantarmos durar a capa das
inseguranças esvaziar essa mochila de
medos e ensino com os meus
saí de subir tornar-me na protagonismo
na protagonista da história da minha
vida e com todos os meus talentos no
final de toda esta viagem interior uma
viagem foi muito íntima foi dolorosa mas
no final desta viagem conseguir resolver
dois problemas um problema no sinal e um
problema econômico com o problema
nacional para resolver o problema da
auto aceitação e com o programa
econômico com a criação da minha empresa
nascida com a descoberta dos meus
talentos
atualmente a minha empresa se dedica à
criação de roupa só roupa para mulheres
e agora homens de todos os lugares do
mundo como corta é procurou que a roupa
seja como da e larga porque acho que a
vida já é demasiado curta é tratada como
eu trabalho simplesmente retiro o pó que
está no espelho e ajudo a tampa de cada
uma das mulheres moçambicanas ou
estrangeiras se beijam exatamente como
são perfeitas
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]